Welcome back everyone this will be my full
ms marvel episode 4 video there were a whole
bunch of easter eggs and references we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
because thor love and thunder is also coming
out we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets for
the movie all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave all your favorite
easter eggs from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the episode yet we'll be covering everything
just starting at the beginning of the episode
we'll work our way through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs and wtf moments as we go along
starting with the episode title it was seeing red
which is a reference to them introducing the
red dagger character from the comics he is a
marvel comic book character the big difference
in this episode is they turned that into a whole
organization they said the entire organization
all just called themselves the red daggers
in the comics it was just one character calling
himself red dagger he was a vigilante from
pakistan he didn't have any special powers like he
wasn't an inhuman like kamala khan was and he came
to america living with her relatives and went to
her school and became a friend of hers over time
within the context of the episode obviously he
lives in karachi the town that they come from
and their order was started because they were
inspired by her great grandmother and it sounds
like they know way more about her culture and
her race of the gin the clandestine characters
it was another info dump kind of exposition
episode where they give you a bunch more backstory
we learned a lot about the history of their
group but there's still a lot of big questions
a lot of what they're getting into here is stuff
that we just saw in doctor strange two with them
going across different universes the multiverse
being a really big thing but obviously they're
trying to play more into the dimensional aspect
here like they say the clandestine are from
another dimension and if you're not a big comic
book reader clandestine is actually an x-men group
so the funny thing is is even though we were
talking about shangshi connections and easter
eggs during episode three a lot of their group at
least in name shares more in common with the x-men
comics also just saw a bunch of x-men stuff during
doctor strange 2. but now you can see why they
released ms marvel as a series after they released
doctor strange multiverse of madness so that you
get a bit of a tutorial in the multiverse before
you get all this multiverse stuff in ms marvel
during this episode like they've done a couple
times previously they play another pop song under
the marvel studios intro it's always a different
pop song sometimes they just play the regular
logo though the actual opening scene was them on
the plane with them heading back to karachi in
pakistan where her grandmother had told them to
come back and visit they have this running joke
with everybody clowning on her for using this
giant sloth as a napping pillow like she calls
it a napping pillow but it's really like a giant
stuffed animal but it's sloth themed because of
her sloth baby youtube channel where she posts
all of her avengers videos the joke about them
calling it a flying teddy bear is also a bit of a
reference to her eventually being able to use her
powers to glide through the air a little bit more
gracefully because the sloth represents her like
she is the sloth baby and even though she won't be
able to actually fly eventually the way that like
captain marvel or vision can actually fly she will
be able to use her light constructs to move across
the air a little bit more gracefully because of
the way they're hyping up next week's episode is
like a big flashback episode i'm not expecting to
see a ton of that in episode five i'm assuming a
lot of the scenes of her using her powers in that
way are actually from the finale they have this
whole subplot with the drama between her and
her mother and her mother and her grandmother
like they want to make it seem like she's more
like her grandmother with her head in the clouds
wanting to be a superhero believing in all this
backstory with the clandestine in the gin and they
do explain a little bit about why the mother came
to america in the drama between her and her mother
but whereas in previous episodes it wasn't clear
how much the mother knew about all this backstory
and how much she was in on all this the way that
they explained it in the episode is that her
mother never believed any of the backstory that
her grandmother or her own mother was telling her
about them being part of the clandestine race
in this alternate dimension just thinking that
it was her being crazy and everybody that lived
near them when she was a little girl thinking of
them as crazy and apparently her father left their
family when she was young and it sounds like she
blames a lot of that on the stories that she was
telling about them being part of the clandestine
race so she wanted to get as far away from that
as possible and that's why she gets so upset when
kamala starts asking about all that stuff so if it
wasn't clear at least up to this point the mother
doesn't seem like she knows anything about this
i think they're trying to tease all three of them
reconciling by the end of the series like kamala
will reconcile with her mother and her mother will
reconcile with her mother too they also remind you
that everyone that's part of her family line has
that same newer ability that she has too they
can make like constructs like that although i
think that the mother and the grandmother would
also have to wear the bangle in order to do that
but when you meet her grandmother they go back to
her house you see that she has drawings all over
her room just like kamala does like they want to
show you that her grandmother is just like she is
the only difference is that in kamala's room
all of her artwork is avengers themed artwork
and all of her grandmother's art are supposed to
be drawings of her life from before the partition
which they actually feature at the end of the
episode when comrade's mother damages the bangle
and she literally sees it in person like all the
drawings are supposed to be some of what she winds
up seeing at the end of the episode so don't worry
i will explain how that works too because that's
sort of like a new wrinkle in the way that we
see characters time travel in the mcu there are a
couple different ways that people can time travel
we've seen a couple of them in the mcu so far
i believe what's happening at the end of the
episode is supposed to be an easter egg from
the lore in real life on the gin characters like
they're supposed to be able to travel on light and
also i believe that they can time travel and they
can change their appearance so far in the mcu the
way we've seen characters been able to time travel
are using quantum energy and technology like iron
man the avengers and avengers end game and he who
remains version of kang the other versions of kang
the conquer we've also seen characters transport
just their consciousness through time like during
x-men days of future past and then it's a bit
of a workaround but you have mcu gods like
amit during the moon night series other cosmic
entities like the living tribunal like the most
powerful cosmic entities they can just perceive
the entire timeline all at once those characters
wouldn't actually be time traveling they'd just be
perceiving all of time simultaneously so it's kind
of like a backdoor workaround for physically time
traveling what's happening to kamala at the end
of the episode seems more like the first method
like traditional time travel like she's actually
time traveling she's going to be learning things
from the past from a version of her grandmother
in the past and she was able to do that using the
power within her in combination with the power of
the bengal unlocking that but it was only possible
because of her biology so it's like a biological
and technological combination workaround for
time travel i think that's what they're hyping
up for next week's episode at least at the
beginning of the episode it'll be something
of a flashback episode where she learns from her
actual grandmother and she sees all this stuff
actually happen that's why i think they wanted
it to look like she was falling through a portal
instead of just passing out and this is
just happening in her mind like she actually
time traveled and obviously the big funny twist
of this whole episode here with her grandmother
is that the grandmother knows everything and
just treats it like it's no big deal like yes
we're all clandestine we're part of this gin race
no big deal just some genetics then a lot of this
middle part of the episode is meant to just be a
tour around karachi and pakistan just to kind of
be like a national geographic episode inside the
mcu like look at what this culture is like it's
just like america everybody is fairly similar
even though their actual culture is very different
everyone acts and feels very similar to people
that you would run into in the united states
like they clown on kamal a lot because she
isn't used to being in pakistan she doesn't
know everything about the culture but like later
she hangs out with red dagger's friends around the
campfire and for the most part their personality
is very similar to the people that she hangs out
with in the united states so a lot of this part
of the episode is just helping her learn about
her own family's history in this part of the
world but also in just showing it to you because
this will be brand new for a lot of people who
just haven't visited that place in the world
when her cousins take her on the tour of the city
they referenced the british raj in the late 1800s
those were the same forces like the british
forces just in general india the victorian era
the british east indies company that her great
grandmother and comrade's mother were trying
to avoid while they were looking through that
ancient ten rings temple for the bengal i talked
about this during my episode three video but the
temple itself in that area was just supposed to be
way more ancient because they'd only been on
earth for about 20 years or so at that time
in present day when kamal is learning about all
this stuff she says that they've been on earth for
about a hundred years so in the flashbacks they
take place in the 1940s they'd only have been
there for about 20 years long enough for kamala's
great grandmother to start a family and have her
grandmother you also notice kamala is walking
around in a new jersey avengers t-shirt like
she has a bunch of avengers fan themed t-shirts
which is mostly meant to be a joke about wand
division because that took place in new jersey
there were two avengers living in the new jersey
area for a little while but also in the comics
there are various splinter groups of avengers all
over the united states like the most famous one
being the west coast avengers there have been a
lot of easter eggs for them during marvel phase
4. like there's a lot of avengers related stuff
just happening on the west coast in general like
she-hulk for instance takes place in los angeles
shangshi ant-man also take place in san francisco
then you have even more obscure groups like the
great lakes avengers everybody always clowns on
the great lakes adventures there's so many jokes
about them just because they're like c and d list
avengers characters that nobody has ever heard of
i'm just waiting for one of these marvel series
or one of these marvel movies to make a joke about
the great lakes avengers then you know it's a deep
cut she goes to the train station to foreshadow
her going to the train station in the flashbacks
at the end of the episode you also notice she's
wearing her comic book accurate looking mask that
bruno gave her previously she finds some artwork
of ant-man drawn on the wall and according to the
description it's part of a series of avengers and
karachi mashup stories it's more of a reference
to how the avengers have become pop culture icons
everywhere around the world like if they weren't
famous before avengers end game all of them are
famous now and it's also a bit of a reference
to kamala khan ms marvel being an avenger type
character in karachi like karachi avengers but
then she meets red dagger at the point of one of
his daggers like she meets the dagger before she
meets the actual red dagger character i've already
explained most of his character he's pretty simple
in the comics like he's just a vigilante from
pakistan where her family comes from who winds up
in her town in jersey city obviously they're using
him a little bit differently during the tv show we
do learn that his knives can break her constructs
i'm assuming that's because they're fortified like
they're special knives because they know so much
about the clandestine race they make references
to teenage mutant ninja turtles in donkey kong
he also claims that he was able to sense her newer
which seems like a pretty big deal that they never
fully explain like either he's trained or there's
some special energy signature that it gives off
that allows him to sense it when he takes her back
to their lair he references the terminator line
come with me if you want to live and then i've
already explained some of the changes that they
made for their group in the comics like they're
calling all of their group red daggers it looks
from the age of a lot of the artifacts and the
items around the room here all the weapons all
the furniture that the group itself was started
after they met her great-grandmother and they were
just inspired by her maybe she also had something
to do with teaching them about their culture it
seems like they have more of a connection to her
great-grandmother than they've told her so far
but then they roll out a whole bunch of advanced
tech when they're giving her that really cool
looking powerpoint presentation on the alternate
dimension so they do have a lot of advanced tech
here that's hidden their leader waleed references
thor landing in the himalayas the joke is that
that's also happened in the comics like thor has
been to the himalayas the himalayas in the mcu are
also where kamar taj is located during the first
doctor strange movie you actually see him stuck
on the mountainside he gives her this whole
mystical powerpoint tutorial on the backstory
of the clandestine race and explains how its
dimension exists in relation to the mcu dimension
or the main mcu dimension and i know there's a lot
of questions about whether or not this place that
they're talking about this alternate dimension
is just an alternate universe and they're just
calling it an alternate dimension but i think the
way he talks about it like this altered state of
existence it really is an alternate dimension they
also clarify how that dimension is separated from
our own and they sort of set up this whole kind
of dormammu doctor strange plot where they're like
if you open the barrier between dimensions the
real threat isn't just blowing up earth it's
actually that they're going to invade earth and
completely absorb our dimension that's basically
what dormammu was trying to do with the dark
dimension during the first doctor strange movie
just absorb the main mcu dimension into his own
dimension the red daggers make it sound like all
the clandestine race are kind of hostile but that
can't be true like if aisha her great-grandmother
was nice that means that other members of
their race are also probably very friendly
the actual inscription on the bengal what you seek
is seeking you is probably a reference to a couple
of different things it's probably both a metaphor
and a literal thing like she's seeking information
about her great-grandmother and she literally
time travels at the end of the episode and will
probably get that information from her actual
grandmother does all that talk about them looking
for the second bengal in the flashbacks and
metaphorically in present day she's searching for
her true purpose in life like she wants to become
a superhero which she will eventually become by
the end of the series then if it wasn't clear the
damage control supermax prison that it seems like
we're seeing for the first time we actually saw
in the she-hulk trailer it's the same prison that
they're keeping the abomination at if you look in
the background it's just that during the she-hulk
trailer it was during the day that we were seeing
it you can see these structures look exactly the
same so it just explains where abomination is
where this prison is located there a couple
prisons like this inside the mcu like the raft is
one of them where you send really powerful super
villain characters this just confirms that they're
trying to help set up the she-hulk series during
the ms marvel series because very literally we're
going to be getting she-hulk episodes in august
the whole thing with comrade's mother leaving him
behind is probably just leading towards a very
star wars kind of luke skywalker darth vader
confrontation at the end of the series where
kamran has to fight her remember komron exists the
same way that kamala khan exists like he has both
human dna and clandestine dna so he can wield noir
the exact same way as long as he has the bangle
you notice when kamala comes back home to her
mother you notice that the mother's eating the
super old toffees that the grandmother had been
saving for her all these years that's why they're
so hard like be careful when you eat those you're
gonna chip a tooth then the red daggers give her
that blue cloth which will eventually become part
of her comic book accurate ms marvel costume from
the comics like eventually she'll use the blue
fabric to create her new super suit the way
they're pacing things though it sounds like she
might not actually create that comic book costume
till the finale then if it wasn't clear when
comrade's mother's group attacks them at the red
dagger's special base it's implied that they've
been tracking her nor and they've just been
looking for komala khan because she has the bangle
like they don't care about the red deckers at all
they're tracking her they have a big chase scene
she's mostly still using her powers on instinct
but she's supposed to be getting better with them
like she creates the larger ramp to protect the
family in the street they also try to pay off the
joke about her being a terrible driver from way
back in episode one when she steals the truck and
accidentally quote-unquote hits one of them like
takes them out oh totally meant to do that then
r.i.p to walid who's killed by kamran's mother
i love how red dagger also doesn't want to check
for his pulse like nope we don't need to check
him he's definitely dead we have to go right now
and if it wasn't clear in the previous episodes
they explained that all the weapons that the
clandestine are fighting them with are made from
advanced techniques and powers so they're meant
to be on par with weapons that you see in avengers
movies like they're all meant to be pretty
hardcore and then like i said before najma damages
the bangle enough to trigger kamala traveling
through time to the actual partition event at
the train station that she just spent looking
at in the pictures of her grandmother so she's
basically supposed to be witnessing everything
that happened that day that her great-grandmother
aisha disappeared after saving her grandmother as
a little girl on that train they keep saying that
the bengal is trying to tell her something but i
think that's meant to be a metaphor for the greek
grandmother like her great-grandmother is trying
to tell her something but you probably noticed
that the entire end credits of the episode was a
totally different scene like the new end credit
scene was meant to be similar to the original
one but all the artwork is around karachi city
instead of jersey city and there are a couple new
pieces of comic book art but most of the art that
you see here is directly out of the comics one of
the brand new pieces is the red dagger character i
don't believe that he was featured in the previous
episodes and credits they also ended on the green
glowing ms marvel logo in the logos for her
name if that wasn't clear in all the previous
episodes it's always the same font for the logo
that's meant to be the same font as the title of
the ms marvel comics but every time in episodes
when you see green glowing energy things i think
of the cree all the captain marvel backstory stuff
that they're trying to tie this to like they want
her powers to make sense when they get to the
captain marvel 2 movie but they haven't completely
explained that connection yet because right now
we're talking about alternate dimensions it has
more in common with a shangshi movie than it does
with the captain marvel movies i think they'll try
to clarify that in the next two episodes like what
does all this have to do with what's happening
during the captain marvel 2 movie but it sounds
like most of episode 5 next week or at least the
first part of the episode will mostly be her stuck
in the past for a hot minute learning everything
she can from her actual great-grandmother aisha
in finding out what really happened to her
and more about her powers just in general remember
they said the last time that anyone ever saw her
was after she saved the grandmother when she
was a little girl using the bengal on this day
so early theories right now is that something
happened to her that day and she somehow
returned to their home dimension and that's where
she's been this whole time or she was killed by
comrade's mother or another member of their group
who just tried to take the bangle from her let me
know in the comments though what do you think
really happened to aisha the great-grandmother
why did she disappear and do you think we'll
actually see that second bangle on the show that
they kept teasing during the flashbacks or do you
think that that's just going to be a red herring
in the comics kamala khan only ever has the
one bengal but the bengal in the comics doesn't
have any special powers it's just like a family
heirloom that she wears to honor her ancestors
there wasn't a ton of m beginning in this episode
we'll probably see her using more comic book
looking powers like she has in the comics in the
last two episodes if you spotted any other big
easter eggs or references during the episode
that i didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments in my full ms marvel
episode 5 video we'll post next wednesday after
they release it i believe they're letting us post
our thor love and thunder reviews next tuesday so
look out for that my post credit scene video my
easter eggs breakdown video for the entire movie
we'll post after it comes out later next week
i'm also working on a new thor bonus video right
now that'll post next sam raimi and the writer
of doctor strange 2 just did a big commentary
revealing a whole bunch of deleted scenes and
easter eggs you can click here to learn about
all the doctor doom during doctor strange 2 and you
can click here for all my thor love and thunder
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!